they have been pushing through this bill
which now has passed this is this is so
absolutely insane
that I actually cannot believe it's
happening like you know we talk about
politics all the time and crazy things
happen and obviously the culture wars
just like endless craziness all the time
right but this one is so nuts that I
actually cannot believe it's happening
in America although I guess maybe it's
not happening in America it's happening
in California which is a whole other
thing what they are doing in California
is we showed you some of the video
Yesterday by the sponsor of the bill who
happens to have a trans daughter if your
seven-year-old child comes home
and says that they are a girl even
though they are a boy if you do not
affirm that for them whatever your
seven-year-old child thinks the state
can now come and take your child away
from you child services can come and now
say your child is not yours in essence
you are abusing your child they will put
that child in some sort of State
Facility or give them to some other
group of people who will literally
chemically castrate them force them to
undergo drugs and procedures and all of
that stuff that is happening in
California right now here is a guy by
the name of California Senator Scott
Wilk he's been a state senator there for
at least a decade and he actually is
sane he has had it and listened to his
message
I'm now in year 11 in in the state
legislature and all the time we're
proposing policies to protect children
well after 11 years I've come to a
conclusion that we need to start
protecting parents that's just not
happening I've been here and witnessed a
full frontal assault on Charter Schools
taking away parents uh choice and how
their children can be educated to the
detriment particularly of children of
color
in recent years we have put government
bureaucrats between parents children and
doctors when it comes to medical care
and now we have this where if a parent
does not support the ideology of the
government they're going to be taken
away from the home now I agree with both
Senator weiner Senator Laird that today
it only involves divorce proceedings and
frankly a judge can already factor
factor this in but I can assure you it's
not going to end with divorce
proceedings in the past when we've had
these discussions and I've seen parental
rights
um atrophied I've I've incur I've
encouraged people to keep fighting I've
changed my mind on that if you love your
children you need to flee California you
need to flee and it just breaks my heart
born and raised in this state I love
this state I'm not going to stay in this
state because it's it's just too
oppressive and I believe in Freedom and
so I'm going to move to America when I
leave the legislature I'm going to move
to America I bet you this guy ends up in
Florida and we would be happy to have
you here so this has now happened in
California you really must understand
this it is on the way it is happening if
you are watching this show and you're in
California and you I don't even have to
say if you're conservative if you're a
roughly sane person and you are sending
your kid to public school or wherever
else if one day that child's mind is
infected and they come home and say this
know that
you live in a place where they can take
your child away if that is not enough to
get you moving I don't know what is I
genuinely do not know what is but they
are it is now State sanctioned
kidnapping in California these people
are completely out of control
[Music]